This one may not be obvious.
The best way to reduce the percent error is actually to use a giant rod.
And what's the reason for that?
The way we calculate percent error is by comparing the absolute error
to some true value.
Since we have a fixed absolute error here of 1cm,
that error doesn't grow even if the shadow gets longer and longer and longer.
This is just the fuzziness associated with measuring a shadow.
We have a fixed 1cm up here.
To make this percent error as small as possible,
we want to divide that 1cm by as large a value as we can.
And the true value of the shadow's length, we can make that larger and larger and larger
by just using a bigger and bigger and bigger rod.